joining us now House Oversight Committee
is the ranking member congressman Jim
Jordan of Ohio Fox News contributor
former Oversight Committee Chair smart
enough to get the hell out of there the
author of the bestseller power grab
jason Chaffetz is with us so here's what
I heard today another beat down a
disastrous day for the Democrats so it
stays behind closed doors now we ever at
least going to get the transcript so we
can show the purse again today the boss
literally say nothing wrong on that call
and there was no alteration of the
transcript more lies told by the leaking
Democrats Jim Jordan yes on I do think
we'll get the transcript sometime but
again it's up to Adam Schiff and Nancy
Pelosi they're making the rules as they
up as they go along they tried to pass
this resolution today and put a ribbon
on this this sham of a process but that
doesn't change it it's still a sham
process so hopefully we'll get the
transcripts at some point they said
they're going to have public hearings
but look when you do this in the in
secret in the bunker and the basement of
the Capitol where the American people
can't see it I think I think they
understand this is this is a flawed
process to the nth degree and the
American people get it it's unfair it's
partisan I don't think they're going to
stand for it and you're right our party
was stayed together and we all voted
against this which I think was a great
sign and a great message to the to the
people of this country well I think it's
just obvious I mean we know what Newt
Gingrich did in terms of Bill Clinton
jason Chaffetz I've gone over it many
times on this program I go over it again
if people want but I mean it was every
consideration every due process right to
call witnesses cross-examine witnesses
deny evidence being admitted admit
evidence all of that was a lot none of
this is allowed you must bow at the feet
of the congenital corrupt compromised
liar and beg for please may we have
permission sir and beg for anything and
then he gets to say no well when Nancy
Pelosi and Adam Schiff did was try to
sell this sham to the American people by
saying now there's a formalized process
and now it's more open and transparent
but literally today the exact day that
they voted on this they were having
transcribed interviews in the dark in
the secret and to
Morrow they're going back into the house
Intel committee is that going to be open
and transparent is that going to be out
on television with reporters and other
members of Congress being able to look
at it think about you have duly elected
members of Congress going into it cannot
go into a hearing that is an
unclassified hearing and that's going to
happen even after this thing passed it
is a total sham it empowers Adam Schiff
more it is becomes more secretive no
matter what the speaker says here's what
I understand why Jim Jordan has got to
be some way if he is a fact witness
which he is just go with the things that
we know we know that there was contact
with the non whistleblower hearsay
whistleblower whistleblower know we have
a right to know what the contact was
don't we have a right to know whether or
not they colluded don't we have a right
to know what the relationship is with
Simon and what did though we have a
right to know what the relationship was
with with John Brennan the biggest Trump
hater most corrupt individual who I
think we're going to learn a lot about
in the dorm investigation don't we have
a right to find out those facts sir John
remember this five weeks ago Adam Schiff
says we need to hear from the
whistleblower today he says we don't
need to hear from the whistleblower what
changed in that five week time frame one
fundamental fact we learned that Adams
shift staff had met with the
whistleblower that's the only thing
that's changed so now Adam Schiff says
oh no no we don't really need to talk to
this guy
so that too I would love to have Adam
Schiff under oath in front of a
committee asking him questions I don't
think it's going to happen but your this
the idea that he's the only guy in
America who knows who this individual is
who started this whole thing and never
forget on the whistleblowers complaint
bullet point number one on the complaint
the whistleblower says this over the
past four months I have talked to more
than half a dozen US officials who form
the basis of this complaint who were
those more than half a dozen US
officials who are these seven to eleven
people well I would like to talk to them
and more importantly the American people
would like to see those people who gave
the whistleblower the information and
judge their credibility under oath in
front of the committee not in secret in
the bunker in the basement of the
Capitol but in an open hearing where we
can ask them questions and they got to
answer them under oath
and we see how they respond that's how
it should work but that's not how it's
going to work because this process as
Jason just said is a sham not only was
the president exonerated by the
transcript jason Chaffetz we see that
the present for three years we've heard
about how horrible outside election
interference of foreign countries is the
president saying to the president of
Ukraine who we know from a Ukrainian
Court that they colluded with Hillary
Clinton the political writes about a DNC
operative meeting in the Ukrainian
embassy in DC to get dirt on Donald
Trump to have Ukraine collude and impact
the 2016 election in her favor
so I guess Donald Trump is well doing
his constitutional constitutional duty
faithfully executing the laws hey give
us any evidence you have and in spite of
what the media says there is a quid pro
quo crazy Uncle Joe you get fire room
you get a billion dollars you don't fire
him you don't get a billion dollars and
you got to fire the guy that's paying my
son Millions was no experience with
Ukraine or energy whatsoever ever I
think that sounds like corruption to me
that sounds like oh he was buying favor
with the Biden's maybe I'm just making
that up though maybe that's a conspiracy
theory Jason well I got to tell you
there's a lot of us that believe that
the reason this rush to this vote
happened when it did is that they know
the Horowitz report is moments away and
they wanted to get out in front of it so
they can concoct this new news field
next week to say oh that's just Donald
Trump that's what he's conducting the
Department of Justice to cover up the
impeachment great that is such a lie but
Horowitz is going to come out he's going
to come up with the truth and it's gonna
be ugly ugly ugly for the Democrats well
they're a little upset about that thank
you both all right and